i have to say something right now and i
was gonna save it for another podcast
but i can't
i'm sorry
but
since you're here and gilbert you guys
are here
something happened to me last week
that was very humiliating for me so i
was at the comedy store with nick
youssef
and he goes here i'm gonna i'm gonna go
do a show at the laugh actor can you
drop me off
it's like okay you know what i'm gonna
go eat a green black so i'll just park
so i park my car and i with nick youssef
and i we walk into the lab factory
and
two people came up to me and goes
where's your ticket
and i go
what
yeah you need a ticket or get out
the staff yeah
they go what what they're kids younger
i don't yo don't two people don't feel
bad i saw kat williams get rejected from
the caroline's christmas party and he
was in a full-length fur coat
you're really trying to tell people
and the girl was like what are you on
the list yeah and she's just brand new
these people they they hire these clubs
they don't feel bad that happened to him
at the left factory too that's what
their point was it happened to cat but
that's not the point no that's not the
point
whatever you're saying right now it
doesn't make any [ __ ] sense okay
sorry go all right
is if you're working at a comedy club in
l.a i'm just i'm not okay let me just
say this i know i'm not chris rock
i know i'm not louis ck i know where i'm
at
all right i'm at the bottom fine bobby
lee you were in a wonder girls music
video all right
but when it comes to the comedy store
and the laugh factor in the improv here
in la
since i've been here for 20 years and
i've played those clubs for 20 years and
i'm friends with the owner of the club
i've been around the country with the
owner of the club i know every single
comic that performs there
i'm on the payroll right that you should
don't you think that they should know
who i am or no
yes probably or at least um whoever you
put up to the front to deal with people
coming in the door should at least be
well versed with who's who yeah so then
when it yeah that's part of your job
don't apply for a job at a comedy club
without doing your research to see who
comedians are or at least just
especially the ones who perform at your
club yeah what did you say to them or
who's in the marquee down the street you
know what i mean like it doesn't well i
said it's so embarrassing but then i go
i'm bobby lee
and he goes no i don't what oh god oh my
god they don't even know the name oh my
god
let's go
because i've never been in this
situation so you're almost like
did they recognize nick youssef no they
asked for his uh and he was on the list
right
yeah he's on the list right so nick goes
um my id i don't i'm performing here
and i'm like i'm a
comedian
like i couldn't get it out right hey
boss we gotta go with down syndrome in
the front of the house
asian guy with down syndrome and then i
just kind of left the building
i just left oh my god and then i told
the doorman who i knew
i go they just asked my days yeah you
know they're new
and i and then i texted everyone i knew
nice i texted crystalia eric griffin um
a bunch of people johnny sanchez
going they wouldn't let me in the laugh
factory
and then i just said i'll never go back
there again
damn over one person's two yes
yes over one person that's the point
okay that's the [ __ ] point of the
whole thing let me say something right
now okay
that's how people learn
okay
and also this
the same thing happened to me i told you
the story about in seattle
oh that's right at the parlor live oh
have i told that story here on the
podcast you can see it again yeah it's
been a while i'll say the story again
i do a show at the parlor live and i'm
sorry but it's not a big room i sold out
every show
i'm sorry i have to say it
sold out every [ __ ] show
okay
i do one show kill it
go to my hotel room
to take a shower
i go back to the second show
and i walk into the club
and the doorman puts his arm out grabs
me and pulls me on the club we're sold
out oh my god
right and i and and every comic that i
tell this dude they said why don't you
just say that you're the headliner
no no no probably doesn't look like that
the headliner you shouldn't have to tell
them who the headliner is everybody on
staff should know who the headliner is
and you know what their picture looks
like exactly and also this is also fun
for me
so when he puts his arm around me i'm
like this is amazing
you like it because this is about to
turn into something
there's a confrontation that's gonna
happen and i i want to see what i'm
going to do
so what i do is i go
i kind of push him aside and i will
continue to walk at the club yeah john
without saying anything was he bigger
than you way bigger he was like this
american indian dude oh they're big get
long hair right and he as i'm walking in
the club he's now
in front of me
walking backwards
whoa whoa you're deaf man
your dad your dad
right
then he finally stops me in my tracks
and he goes ow
so i leave
meanwhile i'm supposed to be on stage
and as i'm walking on the club oh yeah
all right fine i'm leaving but tell
ruben cancel the show
he goes why
because i'm the headliner
and i just leave
right and didn't do the show no wait
mike no i'm of course going to do the
show
but i'm like milking it right
so i'm walking away and then he's now
looking at like the pictures
he's freaking out no he's like oh my god
that is him or whatever
and he starts getting angry
why didn't you tell me
and i'm screaming back look at the [ __ ]
you know man
right
so then i go up on stage i go back get
in the club
and then when i get off it's amazing
there's people in the green room that
i've never seen before
you're talking about the guy that owns a
whole building
you know i mean like like investors you
know i mean they're all there [ __ ] and
they're like oh
we're so sorry we fire them
and i go no
i felt guilty
right
so then i had i spent 24 hours begging
to get that guy's job back
are you serious yeah so it could have
been bobby this is how it works so it
could have been it could have been as
simple as this
i'm the headliner i just walked in and
did my show and nothing we got i had to
do this complete [ __ ] chaos and it's
so fun to do
and i enjoy it
you know i mean so with this laugh
factory thing i'm never going back until
somebody apologizes ah
get it what you don't get it i mean i do
you do get it right you're a drama queen
that's really weird okay he's just
asking for the respect no but he really
likes he he loves to make
a bigger fuss about it trust me make a
point
beyond that he wants people to learn a
lesson he loves the drama
it's not drama that's a weird way of
saying it
i enjoy
a spectacle it's like performance art
it's a performance
thank you so much and let me tell you
something they're friends again huh you
better yeah i like that i don't like
this i like that but it's like um
so when open micro goes i'll see her on
the circuit
right i get what it is it's like him
trying to go i'm a comic too yeah i've
got you don't know me i'll be around the
same thing but i want to tell that
person no no you're not no you're not
you know
and um you should whisper it
in their ears yeah so creepy i've done
through a glass oh my god dude there's
this girl you throw a glass at a girl no
i'll get to the wall
of the in the hallway the squirrel walks
down the hall oh my god i can't believe
i talked about this a long time ago yeah
she walks down
and she like goes get out of the way
to me i'm standing there with a drink
okay like a coke or something i go i'm
not getting out of the way i hear your
mind
she goes i'm a comic
all right i go i'm i go i'm a comedian
as well
i think yeah but you know we're both
comic because you just get out of the
way
okay like she's walking through or
whatever yeah
so go you how
how many times have you performed here
she's like three times you know
and i go okay
i'm going to show you the kind of power
i have oh i think i remember you
yeah yeah what makes me say she goes i
go i go stand back she stepped back i
took the glass i threw it against the
wall and shattered and then brett middle
calm brenton middle comb sweeped it in
the back walked away and i got there's
nothing they can do about it
what are you in a movie why are you in a
movie who is this girl i never saw her
again of course not she's terrified
they're throwing glasses yeah it was uh
and and so then that was that and then i
jumped into stand-up fully so i started
being around the comedy store more and
uh and then i remember doing a set this
is what i was doing maybe twice a month
and i was upstairs in the belly room
and bobby uh
was up there and you know he's just so
like so uh great about like seeing
people and if he sees somebody he likes
he'll stop you and say something to you
say that again
if bobby's so great about uh
first of all
hanging around for a little bit and
watching other comics and he would float
around to the rooms and he was upstairs
in the belly room and he saw me and then
and i had a good set so he pulls over he
goes how come i haven't seen you before
and i was like oh i only come around a
couple of times a month because i just
i've been one fitting one foot out my
girlfriend [ __ ] the camera guy he's
like that's not what i asked like how
come i haven't seen you know i was
giving too much information right out of
the gate and he's like you're really
funny he's like could you follow me
downstairs in the original room if right
now for 20 minutes if i brought you down
there and you know like you don't want
to be like i don't think i'm ready yet i
just i think i need to work on it so i
was just like [ __ ] yeah i could you know
so he goes come on so he walks
downstairs he goes to tommy the booker
and he's like tommy put uh this guy up
after me and uh and tom was like well i
think he's gonna pee around more and
he's gotta like which was the right move
because i would have uh tanked but also
would have been great for me and uh
that's ridiculous and then tommy goes
and then tommy goes i have seen him
around but he needs to be around more
like he needs to hang on the sunday
monday open mics yeah and then you
suggested maybe you should try to like
work there just because you'll get more
spots and whatever and i at that point
had no reason to not jump in fully
because you know when you first started
standing up there did you work there
yeah i did the phones on fridays i
didn't want to do like
the door or the parking lot right
i don't know why i was uh i just wanted
to but i wanted to be around and have a
way to communicate because a lot of
comments would call for reveals and
there was a way that i could actually
like chum them up a little bit on the
phone and then later that night be like
hey what's up man they're like oh yeah
it's the best i mean if you're a new
comic it's the best way i was invited to
get into the um
our eyesight yeah because when you're
there all the time like
i'm bringing
what's this asan to san antonio this
weekend oh cool i've never seen him but
he does the parking lot yeah everyone
says he's good yeah he's a nice guy yes
and he's just there yeah
right so i have a side out of mind right
that's a real i decide i don't mind yeah
i mean they're just there so i wouldn't
you i used will burkhart but through
you know what we're not word of mouth
but um with brent moore and jason
collins speaking highly of him but
that's rare most of my guys are from the
comedy store yeah you told me a week
after that you were like i have i think
kevin christie couldn't do a college gig
and you're like if you can't go you're
you want to come and i just was like
immediately because was that the one in
north carolina it was north carolina and
somebody ended up i think nick went and
said somebody something happened but
then you said but i'm gonna find
something else so you like what you also
didn't have to do and then i think the
more i was around and then you and then
you get to see me more you know and then
uh but you did [ __ ] me a couple of times
huh house on the road
i lost six thousand dollars because of
you you robbed bobby
uh no do you remember i do remember
yeah i had met a girl i was in a hotel
room
i had met a girl listed in fort
lauderdale yeah yeah and i got you know
the story don't question it
i think the details are kind of coming
back
we well by the way this was right
we should mention this is i think after
before we went to 7-eleven bobby does
this great thing on the road with you
too where he
i don't know if it's a called taking
advantage of his power is that the way
is that the right way to award it
where he would tackle me in the green
room and the host is like welcome to the
stage adam ray and he's in kansas city
literally holding me down on the ground
and laughing and the and adam ray and
people are clapping and then it stops
and then the host is like are you bo are
you back there are you okay and bobby's
just laughing and finally had to punch
him to get me off him yeah yeah or he's
like hey eat these 20 oysters i'm like i
hate oysters i might be allergic
i might be allergic he's like do you
want to go to phoenix next weekend
i love you guys
yeah and so uh
like him and i think you're going to get
mad sweetie and then i i i'm going to be
able to just i want to i was going i was
going to say this to you tomorrow i was
like seal oh no yeah scared don't be
scared
um but
i just uh but just i just hear me out
i'm gonna tell you what happened why are
you scratching your nuts
no i'm not scratching my nerves this is
nervous
tick is a nervous tic and i was gonna
you know and you can say no and then
i'll have to deal with it and i don't
want to fight about it right i'm just
going to ask you something okay okay
uh-oh
so monday
what you know you know how we call in at
the comedy store right
yeah right yeah you call in
right and you go they go what when do
you available that you can go up and i
go i said all week uh-huh okay
so this guy jay the skinny little guy
named jay goes okay
and he told this guy fat black guy named
quincy i i know
i shouldn't be saying race humanoids
something like that okay that's just the
way i'm just trying to change you know
what i mean it's okay man and quincy
forgot to tell adam i already know what
you're going to ask me what
we are not going to go to joshua i am
doing joshua tree
okay
but good one god what is your problem
right now that's exactly it it's not it
can we not go till like monday no no
we're gonna go sunday okay but after
your show no no not after the show
will you listen to my thing
there's a lot of energy here i'm very
confused with it right yeah
so um
anyway so that happens so then they then
they call me and go they go you got no
spots
yeah i remember that you remember that i
was upset you were at the dog park and
then the all week and then all week
they've been calling like you can be on
the fallout
okay that's not gonna change it you guys
[ __ ] me right
but then adam called me and goes you're
still doing my benefit show sunday right
at eight
hours how okay right and i said oh yeah
okay so can i do the benefit show as i
go
can i go to la joshua street and if you
say no and you're and you say no then
i'll just call him go no i'm not i'm out
why are you asking me this yeah
because it's better to do it this way
because
i don't want to start a fight you can
say no and i'm not going to be upset
well let's break this i can call adam
right now let's break this down yeah
yeah interesting you knew that i had
made plans that's not true i'm gonna
tell you why why because apparently i
said yes to this months ago what the
josh retreat no the the benefit show
for adam okay and you know me i forget
okay
so then joshua tree came along
completely forgot about the benefit show
and then now we were supposed to go to
joshua street sunday and stay till
wednesday or thursday right i'm even
willing to stay an extra day
so that we can make this happen
i'm open to anything that you want me to
do if if it's important
listen listen to me yeah
you already know the answer i know but
this is i have never ever gotten into it
but i don't want you to get angry or
like sad or like call me a liar or
anything like that there's i never want
to get in the way of your stage time
it's not stage time i don't even want to
do it but he said
you know i mean you're still doing it
right and
i said yeah and then i forgot you're and
i don't want you to look bad in front of
adam and i don't want you to flake on
another person i would rather you flake
on me than flake on them that way i'm
not flipping expecting you i'm saying
we're gonna go right after her
yeah but it's a two-hour drive so we'll
probably not get there till midnight
still fine
so fun it was still gonna be an
adventure still fun fine are we good
yeah we're good and you're not upset or
anything like that can i get a buffalo
no a little bit no no no no no
the only reason i'm upset is because
you needed george and gilbert to be here
as
a buffer so i wouldn't like
figuring out why you were doing it now
like but isn't that a brilliant way of
doing it
would you throw me that though
that i did it in the most brilliant way
babe that was perfect shadow play yeah
it was can i get a bubble though i don't
know yeah you need to i love you you
need to lie
give me a baby baby it's on
youtube youtube
that was the most disgusting
why did you blow air into his mouth
i didn't it's because i laughed and
snapped
oh good can i just tell you something
that happened to me there yet today this
morning
so i can't get into detail about it but
i booked an abc
pilot
uh-huh okay
and i um i shot last week
and this morning
i had to shoot at 5 30 in the morning
and um i'm on set i had to pee
and they said upstairs um
was the vip bathroom
okay
from the side we're shooting in a house
so i go upstairs and i pee in the
bathroom about to pee
and the sec direct decorator walks in
she goes hey you're not supposed to be
up here
i go just they said this is the
yeah that's how i said it too because
because i know
as soon as she confronts me i know fun
is about to happen you love this i love
when confrontation happens because then
i play it the other way
she goes this is only for you know i
mean series regular you know what i mean
the you know i mean background it's on
the other right around the corner
just by your little strip
i look like background
if you don't know bobby lee seriously if
you don't there's no way they're gonna
put this on tv
you have to know to know there's no they
put everyone on tv yeah but
look flat come on be real though i
completely agree because that happens to
me all the time right am i right they
think that you're
yeah we're like a cameraman or a sound
not even that what they just think i'm
not supposed to be there at all
just walked on set no because i laugh
because that's exactly how i feel it's
terrible yeah so what happened did you
say hey no no no of course no no you got
to make it weird yeah spectacle so i
pulled my penis back in because my back
was
it was
i was about to pee and she from behind
right so i turn around i go oh okay
so i will go downstairs and i go to the
head like you know i mean 80 or whatever
i go i thought you sit upstairs oh god
he loves it
i couldn't i could have stopped it by
saying no i'm on the show yeah and then
just went out my merry way i'm done
no
you can't do it that way okay
[Music]
so i thought you said that upstairs was
vip it is go pee we have to shoot
you know what i mean like they're
calling you but the
lady
[Laughter]
upstairs she said that i can't so she
goes up there okay then i hear all this
like commotion
that's great i'm down there smiling like
looking up at that you know at the
ceiling
hearing what's going on
and then i walk up and then she's like
i'm sorry you can be i'm sorry you know
what i'm in and i pee oh my god she
probably got fired i
the know thing happened when i did that
um
what's steve glittman show that he did
that that boy band show on nickelodeon
oh yeah i forget the name you know that
it's uh they're called they were a boy
band if they had his own and nickelodeon
i know
but anyway i guess start on that and
when i showed up
the lady goes you're in there so i
stayed in a
extras
stable oh she just for like an hour a
stable it was like it was a heart it was
like 50 people around
i knew i wasn't supposed to be there i
could have just said no i'm guest
starring you [ __ ] love that god
all right
i'm supposed to go in there and i just
sit there with them and the whole hour
i'm just full of glee
because i know there's gonna be a moment
of like
why didn't you tell me i don't know you
just told me you know what i mean that
whole thing right that's why i live
that's why i haven't killed myself you
know what's so funny though i feel like
that's a very la thing like they they
treat you based on what they know you
from so when i uh did this small thing
for my friend they're shooting like this
youtube red thing i can't really talk
about that but they i got on there can
you talk about it because i'm not
supposed to yeah i was supposed to talk
about